du cinéma pour terminer avec le
séduisant george clooney dans un rôle
assez inattendu le comédien se lance
dans la science fiction dans solaris qui
sort demain dans les salles elle
interprète le rôle d'un médecin envoyé
en mission dans un monde parallèle
pas d'effets spéciaux comme on pourrait
s'y attendre mais plutôt une méditation
métaphysique sabine dernier amateurs de
science fiction avec gadgets et effets
spéciaux à l'appel passez votre chemin
solaris c'est plus un voyage cérébrale
intersidéral et quand le beau george
enfile sa combinaison de cosmonaute
c'est pour jouer un psychiatre
dépressive depuis la mort de sa femme
appelé à la rescousse dans un vaisseau
spatial ou se passe de drôles de choses
du sang des disparus suicide plus là il
découvre l'incroyable vérité la planète
solaris a le pouvoir de recréer les
êtres que vous avez aimé ou perdu gilles
nantet filomène et or white et dead
le film pose des questions métaphysiques
est ce que dieu existe que se passe-t-il
après la mort l'amour ou la conscience
peuvent-elles survivre à la mort comment
notre mémoire peut réinventer le passé
entre autre interrogation solaris est un
remake lie à 30 ans le russe andreï
tarkovski avait déjà mise en image cette
rêverie métaphysique mais aux acteurs en
lévitation soderbergh a préféré le
sex-appeal et l'émotion d'un george
clooney pour monter et sensuelle à
souhait juste une belle histoire d'amour
qui défilent espace temps le public
féminin n'en demandait pas tant depuis
20 ans hélas les films de
science-fiction privilégie l'action à
l'exception peut-être de matrix combiner
les deux l'anticipation est aussi une
réflexion philosophique c'est ça qui me
plaît
un acteur en mission spatiale un peu
spécial le séducteur de ces dames
contrairement aux flux qu'il a coproduit
avec soderbergh son meilleur ami parole
d'actrice clooney sous les tournages
n'engendre pas la mélancolie t il est
irrésistible et ont le plus drôle que je
connaisse alors que ce soit pour clooney
qui donne envie de changer de planète
pour l' atmosphère troublante et glacée
d'un voyage métaphorique solaris vaut la
peine d'être explorée